i've got two cream eggs making two
pendulum
two pendular i should
come on
this is about coupled pendulums
this is a bit of string and from the bit
of string i've dangled two pendulum
going through a cream egg with a little
button on the bottom to make sure that
it doesn't slip off
now then if i bang one of these pendulum
forwards like this
it will eventually stop again look
i bang it like that
at a later time it's stationary
and at a later time it is stationary
it's magic
and i remember a magician showing this
on a television show where he put a
handkerchief in front and say now it's
stationary
and it would be and then he'd open this
one up and say now this is stationary
and it would be this is magic
only it's simple laws of physics at work
we call these coupled oscillators the
reason is this is one oscillator and
that's another one but they're coupled
in a funny way through the string at the
top and there are little forces as this
goes out of line that pull from one to
the other transferring energy from this
one which is now coming to a rest here
over to that one and then back again
have fun for easter and remember use
hygienic needles if you're going to eat
the eggs afterwards
you